okay so just guess we'll start now I'm
just a pretty fund announcement that in
case you haven't seen all the talks are
available on sort of in recorded form on
YouTube and they're putting them up
really fast and they're doing a very
good job almost after the you know less
than a day after the talk is done it's
already on YouTube it's accessible from
page so you can look at all the old
talks and yes so today we're entering
the fhe phase of the workshop so today
and tomorrow we'll see fully morph
encryption start from me and our first
speaker is Alaric you Lottie
who is and also at Zama in Paris started
a face turn and she will give an
introduction to sort of the basics of
fhe and also a bit about her particular
fhe scheme that she's been working on
quite a bit it's practical
so thanks Larry thanks a lot for the
introduction and also thanks a lot for
all 12 the organizers and to everybody
that is here everybody is doing fine
with this a tough period
so as Vadim already introduced I'm gonna
talk about fhc in general in the first
part of the talk and tfhe in the second
part so everybody when you need to ask
question because maybe is not clear
enough please write a question in the
chat I will try to take a look to the
chat as much as much as possible in case
I don't see any messages feel free to
ping me on that so as I said the talk is
gonna be divided in two parts the first
part is only a freedom amorphic
encryption and the second part is gonna
be tfhe and for tfhe i will describe the
basic construction and then I will
concentrate a little bit more on gate
with trapping and on the evaluation of
the lookup table and I will just keep at
the end of few implementation results
okay so am amorphic encryption on
America encryption schemes are a family
of encryption scheme that allows us to
perform computation on ciphertext on
encrypted messages and in order to
perform those computations we don't need
to know the secret or
access that message themselves just the
decipher text so in the most generic
case imagine that you have two messages
m1 and m2 and those messages are
encrypted so like in this light the
encryption is represented by the green
box and what we would like to do is to
add the OMA more difficult to ciphertext
or multiply the no no more difficulty
and we expect as a result our ciphertext
encrypting the addition of the two
messages or their multiplication so in
the slide that I know today oma morphic
operations and the operation on the
plaintext in a different way not only
because they might be different spaces
but also because very often there are
morphing operations in here are not
exactly as an addition or a
multiplication they might be something
more complicated of course we would like
in more generically to evaluate any
possible function not only additions or
multiplications simple additions or
multiplications we would like to work on
different message spaces so the scheme
you are gonna see today and tomorrow
during those apt talks so I'm gonna
treat them binary messages approximate
messages into integer messages and so on
and this scheme could be generally in
the secret key setting so the secret key
is used to encrypt into the crypto but
of course we can also define a public
key to encrypt and of course keep the
secret key to decrypt so in my talk I
will mainly concentrate on secret key
version of of the stream so why is an
American Christian that's interesting in
practice the reason is mainly because of
the large amount of application it can
allow you to solver you think about any
possible application that involves
sensitive data on a morphic encryption
can potentially help you to solve this
this application every time you treat
the medical data biological genomic you
can do operations in a secure way by
using homomorphic encryption
most generally you can do any kind of
outsourced computation so imagine there
is a client and the server and the
client want to
send some data to the server of course
it doesn't want the server to know which
kind of data is treating but thanks to
am American Christian the server could
perform the operation the manipulation
even without knowing which messages is
is treating and many many other
application I just noted in this slide
electronic voting multi-party
computation but really there are large
amount of application that you could
stone so I'm American Christian is not
an extremely new idea actually we heard
talking about it into for in 1978 when
Rivest add lemon in there to Zoe's talk
about privacy MOF isn't so their idea
was already in 1978 to have a OMA
morphic encryption scheme in some sort
of way as we intended today but
unfortunately for more than 30 years
nobody was able to find a practical
solution a solution actually not even
practical just a solution and the first
solution was proposed only in 2009
almost 30 years later by Gentry which
presented the First Folio amorphic
encryption scheme so when I say fully
OMA morphic what I mean is that it's
able to evaluate any possible operation
is any possible function so why we
needed 30 years to come up with the
first fully monarchic solution and the
question is actually majorly important
when you observe that in the mean time
between 1978 and 2009 already we had
many many schemes that were or morphic
RSA algorithm Akali are just examples
but they are partially amorphic so when
i say partially OMA morphic i mean that
they are able to evaluate as instance
the addition or the multiplication but
not both operations at the same time so
this is why partially and after those
teams so we already start seeing even
before 2009 some scheme there were more
than partially OMA morphic but add some
limited limitation sorry very often we
are talking about some more thermo
morphic encryption schemes or level doma
morphic those two terms
are very often not distinguished I like
to distinguish them and I give you an
example of a Samata morphic encryption
which is not as the instance level so
the example is the scheme proposed a
2005 by bonnie going massima and that
this scheme is able to perform any
amount of additions that you would like
but only one multiplication so it's not
leveled it's just somewhat level scheme
instead i'll arm able to perform both
addition and multiplication as many as
you want potentially but up to a certain
limit so to explain you why there is
this limit i will try to use a very nice
example a fully amorphic encryption
scheme that i will present in is level
mode which is DG HD so the judge fee is
proposing 2010 by Van Dyck and country
11 by Granada and this scheme is based
on the approximate DCP problem which is
a problem based on lattice so the scheme
i'm ieaving very many things under the
carpet just to give you an idea but the
scheme in its initial form encrypted
binary messages it can be extended to
larger message space but for the sake of
this example we just need binary
messages so the scheme uses a pub a
secret key sorry P that I called P which
is a large odd integer and in order to
encrypt the message m it just provides
an addition between and the message m
itself the secret key P multiplied by a
large randomness q and all of this added
by a small randomness arm that we call
generally know is so x through now to
decrypt of this decipher that encryption
is very easy for the crypt is easy as
well you just need to reduce modulo P
and then to reduce modulo Q and to
reduce modular - sorry so the interest
of the scheme is that he has amo morphic
properties so imagine that we have two
ciphertext she wants to encrypt in two
messages and
- with respect to the same secret key P
what happens if you try too hard the
ciphertext
well you retrieve a new ciphertext
encrypting the addition of the two
messages so the addition is an addition
modulo two actually so what will you are
performing in Zacks or gate and if you
perform a multiplication in a similar
way you will obtain a ciphertext
encrypting the product of the two
messages which in this case correspond
to a NAND gate now what I would like you
to concentrate on is the part that I put
in read the noise and you can observe in
the first case that the noise is double
compared to the original quantities
while in the second case in the case of
the multiplication the noise has grown
even more than that is almost on the
square around the square of the two
original noises so of course if you need
to perform just a bunch of additions and
multiplication this shouldn't be a huge
problem
since the R is chosen way smaller than P
but as long as you start to compute too
many many operations in particular
multiplication which make the noise grow
faster then you might reach a certain
limit that prevents you from decrypting
in a correct way so the two options are
possible or you choose your parameters
larger enough in order to evaluate more
operation otherwise you risk to not be
able to decrypt at the end so this is a
bit to give you just the idea of why
there is a there is a problem in level
doma morphic encryption scheme and why
where is the problem so this of course
is not just a problem the B ghv scheme
has all the schemes that we are going to
see during the world this workshop are
gonna have the same problem illustrated
in a different way but there is always
this noise problem so all the on a
morphic ciphertext that we know at least
until now use noisy ciphertext and this
noise need to be taken into account when
we do operations so since there is this
limit the scheme cannot be fully OMA
morphic they cannot evaluate anything so
that the solution to this problem attak
given by the noise
was fined in 2009 by Gentry which
proposed a technique called
bootstrapping
and now I I don't want to enter too much
into detail about strapping I just would
like to give you the high-level idea of
what is happening in bootstrapping so as
I said before we have animal market
encryption scheme and I noted in the
slice with this blue box so and we can
put any message inside this automatic
encryption scheme and now of course this
is here's a morphic properties we can
use it to evaluate a certain function a
circuit and I call this function fee and
so I expect that after the evaluation of
field the result I'm gonna retrieve is
an encryption in the blue box of theof M
so the result of this evaluation now at
the beginning of the computation as I
said there is a little amount of noise
that is put in the ciphertext for
security reason and this noise grows
when we perform computation so what I
would imagine in this slide is that the
function fee is a number of computation
there is large enough there is large
enough yes to reach a certain limit that
I put with this red line and this limit
means that if you perform even a single
operation after this limit you might
risk not to be able to decrypt your
message okay so now what is the easiest
way to the get rid of the of the this
noise well very easily decrypting the
ciphertext why because decrypting makes
you retrieve your message and gets
completely rid of the noise but of
course imagine that you're doing this
operations on the cloud in order to
decrypt you have to give him the secret
key but why giving him the secret T if
you encrypt it at the beginning so what
it was the reason to encrypt at the
beginning and so you you don't wanna of
course give the secret key another
option could be that the cloud sends you
back the noisy ciphertext you decrypt it
and then you send it back with a fresh
noise as in the beginning but this is
not always practical in particular when
you want to avoid loss of community
between clients and clouds so the idea
that country proposed is still to
evaluate a decryption secret to get rid
of the noise but not to do it in clear
text to do it instead in ciphertext in
Alma morphing by evaluating the
decryption circuit ohm ohm Oracle II so
there is that you put your cipher text
you're noisy ciphertext encrypting fill
them inside a new cipher text so you
create a second layer of encryption so
you're all the cipher text field
encrypting few of them becomes your new
message and nothing changes in the
message so the noise is still at the
higher limit but is not increased them
and then since you're encrypting for the
first time with the green cipher text of
course you're gonna have a little bit of
noise in the green thermometer now you
want to do what we want to do is that
you wanna increase the blue ciphertext
inside the green box and to do this
opening you need a blue key so the blue
key is the secret key of the blue
encryption scheme you're not gonna give
it in clear text you're gonna give it
instead encrypt it under the green
cipher text in a green box so now that
you have all those ingredients what you
can do is to evaluate a morphic ally
with respect to the green cipher text
the decryption secret of the blue
encryption and the result of this
computation if performed correctly will
be an encryption only with respective to
the green encryption scheme of T of M
and the message that was hidden inside
the blue ciphertext now what we would
like is that of course decryption is a
set of operation so since they are a
more tech operation they will make the
noise grow but what we hope is that
after the evaluation of this description
circuit in the noise thermometer that is
still enough space to perform at least
another or morphic operation so the
arctic properties tells you that if you
have an imam arctic encryption schema
that is able to evaluate the decryption
secret and an additional one operation
at least one operation that your scheme
is a bootstrap table and you can have a
fully amorphic encryption construction
because you can iterate the
the bootstrapping which is this
technique with another operation
bootstrap you perform the operation of
course if you can perform more operation
between a bootstrapping and the other is
always better but at least one operation
is more than enough for your mom or if
ik encryption now a few a few remarks on
this light I already noticed that there
is a little typo so you can completely
ignore this public key in here as I said
public here secret key we don't really
care I said I will keep secret key in
all this talk and this is a typo so just
forget about this and another thing I
wanted to say is that this key that we
give encrypted with respect to the green
no box is so is an encryption of a
secret key and it's gonna be called in
the rest of the talk
bootstrapping key so is the key that is
needed to perform bootstrapping any
questions until now I don't see anything
in the Q&A so I assume I can continue
okay so a bootstrapping as you can see
is is not a cheap operation is actually
quite costly in practice so their works
that were presented after gantries odd
there is a question in the Q&A so do the
two keys do to be different because one
in PK - no not necessarily
I just put them different just - and
also they're the different colors - to
show that to make a distinction between
the two schemes but it's not mandatory
that - the two keys are different they
can be also the same key in this case we
talked about circular security because
they he should be encrypted under the
key itself but is it's okay does this
answer your question okay perfect okay
[Music]
so as I said the bootstrapping is very
very costly their works that follow the
work by the entry tried to propose
automatic encryption scheme that
didn't need to perform the strapping
that often or in case we needed to
perform bootstrap but to try to improve
this technique to make it as faster and
as possible
so since bootstrapping is very costly
very often we ask the question is really
boost rapping needed to have to do a
mimetic encryption or not in practice
and the answer at least from my point of
view is no you don't always need to
boost rapping it really depends on the
application you are trying to to solve
so in cases instance if you know already
which function you need to evaluate it
so you know the depth the number of
operation you want to perform what you
can do is to try to find a set of
parameters that is large enough to
support this amount of operations and in
this case we talked about level doma
more thick because you don't need to
perform any bootstrapping and this this
parameter are sufficient enough to
evaluate the function you have in mind
otherwise if you're looking for a more
flexible solution more dynamic solution
or if just you don't know which function
is going to be evaluated then you can
use the fully American krypton schemes
so allow bootstrapping
so set the parameters at the beginning
fix your bootstrapping keys and so on
and then with those parameters with this
scheme you can possibly evaluate any
possible function as you can imagine of
course these two flavors of a memetic
encryption has pros and cons in lebanon
morphic the evaluation are faster
compared to the freedom american
christian solution but as i said the
death must be known in advance
while in full emo morphic encryption you
have slow evaluation mainly because from
times to times you have to evaluate the
bootstrapping but at least you don't
have any def limitations okay yes so
nowadays the scheme that we know there
are freely morphic are mainly based on
lattice problems this is why fully
immersive encryption is in the English
workshop so the scheme that we know are
based on at least from from what I
remember are based on three major
problems
approximate GCD like I show you in in
the de gea stream before we have an true
solutions and LW en wrinkle wh solution
I see that there are more questions what
is the difference between SH E and LH e
schemes so as I give an example with
Bonnie gonna seem so in it's not often a
difference is the difference that I'm
mainly making in this in this talk and
of course if you many people may not
agree but what I mean with SH E is that
they can perform addition and
multiplication and ever limit level
homomorphic encryption you can perform
as many as you want as long as the
parameters allow you so in the case of
the ghv sorry not digitally Bonnie
Konaseema it's more or less HD scheme
because you can perform as many
additions as you want but just one
multiplication so it's not level in this
sense
I hope this was okay I have another
question do we need to encrypt the Alpha
M into the green box what is alpha M and
another question is if a secret which
needs to be a morphic evaluated but the
input comes from multiple parties ours
should split the private key secure
multi-party computation can be a
candidate
well of course secure multi-party
computation is a solution in case you
have multiple parties in case of a
morphic encryption you have the multi
key solutions that's I'm gonna I'm not
going to talk about them in this in this
in this talk but there are multi key
solution and there is a way to split the
key between the participants I see that
Vadim wants to answer this question I
think the question is about you know you
bootstrapping picture the next picture
yes yes I'm gonna go back what is alpha
[Music]
ah okay okay okay sorry Sophie doesn't
need to be encrypted I mean fee if for
me are like a set of additional
multiplications operations in general
it's not necessary to encrypt the
operation and the important thing is to
encrypt the data but there are solutions
to to perform secret hiding so maybe you
don't hide the operation but at least
the result doesn't give you any
information about it also you might
choose to to hide the operation by
evaluating a generic function as a
lookup table but yeah the question is
not necessarily I I don't need to hide
the necessary fee at least that this was
not my my point so similarly I think the
question was you know because you said
you moved from public key to secret key
encryption right yes
it seemed like the bootstrapping
operation would need to encrypt we need
to put the blue box inside yes you're
right you're right these need a public
key probably well we so yes it's a it's
a very nice point thanks for for for
it so in something column that I didn't
say at the beginning is that I say we
just consider a secret key let's forget
about public key obtaining a public key
encryption scheme you know morphic
encryption is extremely easing starting
from a secret geomorphic encryption
scheme if you publish a list of
ciphertext encrypting 0 & 1 generally
then you can I think also some scheme
you just need that an encryption of 0
but whatever if you just publish a list
of encryption of 0 you have a public key
in practice and so you can encrypt
whatever you like so yeah it's a it's a
fair point this should be a public key
encryption scheme I it's it's a very
good point
I don't know it tastes answer this the
question so I guess one other way to
solve this problem is to say that you
know the green box doesn't need to be a
random encryption of five of them it
just could be any interruption of fire
friends as long as you can produce like
some encryption could be the identity
function in that you know in the schemes
that we are yes absolutely absolutely
yes absolutely thanks for the remark
okay I suppose the questions are that is
yes okay okay so where I was here so as
I was saying many lattice problems we
can be used to a define encryption elma
market encryption in this workshop and
in the rest of the presentation I will
only concentrate on lwe and Ringle w
based solutions so very quickly in here
I will give you a list of some of the
wrinkle W E and W in wrinkle W based
scheme so consider that this list of
course is not a complete list there is
way more in the literature that that
could be included but of course for
reason of space and the time of this
talk I will not be able to report every
every
so I I would say that the first OMA
morphic encryption scheme based on not
fully mam or fake encryption scheme
based on ring lwe is their BGP or BV
scheme proposing 2011 and 2012 by
brickowski gantry and backward anthem
so this is the the first scheme based on
market encryption scheme based on LW if
we don't consider reggae which was still
additive amorphic and I will I put BGP
like scheme because I'm gonna give us
him that a list of scheme that are bid
you be like I would try to explain later
what I mean with this so after the BGP
construction there was not later not
more later there was the BFD
construction which is very similar to
the first one there are some some little
differences by brickowski fun and
catherine and in 2014 we saw a different
stream that appeared as W so the scheme
just W the construction of GSW is still
lwe ring lwe based but there are some
difference with the BGP like skin zone
as instance in BGP we have a smaller
ciphertext in just W the ciphertext are
are larger the multiplication is done in
a different way in BGP you multiply all
the elements of the ciphertext and then
you do a procedure which is called
really ization while ingestible you know
performs directly in the multiplication
in a special way and also the noise
growth in the multiplication at least in
the two schema is a bit different
generally and just W the noise grows a
bit slower compared to B G B so the
schemes are very interesting both of
them but at the beginning at least from
from what I felt is the bgv scheme was
looked more and more interesting because
mainly because of the size of cipher
text which ingestible you were quite
large compared to the to the first
family I would say that GSW
was improved and a nice improvement was
proposed in 2015 by you kind me Changjo
so they proposed the scheme which is
called phew and which is just a
volume-based and that shows that
actually even with just a volume we can
perform quite fast operation and I will
give a little bit more detail later in
the stock
so after if hcw are together with Nicola
Gama Maryam al-khawaja Bhushan we
proposed the tfhe construction which
initially improved the fhw scheme and
then took a little bit a different
direction and the most recent schema is
again in the BGP like skin and it's the
steam Han proposed by cheon kim heemin
song thousand seventeen so those kim are
I just put them in in those two big
families mainly because of the way the
multiplication is performed but there
are of course many differences between
all of them as instance if we take the
BGP family bgv and bfv are encrypted
mainly integers while he is encrypting
approximate numbers and so there are
many little differences but all of the
scheme in this list and all their
improvements are in practice lwe and
ring and w/e based construction and
adhere and if we take a look a little
bit more closer to all those
construction we see that they are not
actually that different as they are
expected and actually is very easy to
move from one scheme to another and this
was shown in 2017 in 2019 in the Kimura
construction by Bora gamma your Java and
Java and they built a common framework
where they showed that chief Ichi Haiyan
and if we can be used simultaneously or
at least we can move easily between one
and another and all of these are are
theoretical of course so constructions
but all of them are also implemented and
we have many implementation that now are
available here is just a list is not an
exhaustive list again just a bunch of
scheme so that we
that we can find online and as instance
HT Lib was I think the first of all no
more fake encryption scheme that the
first oh no more fake encryption library
and then many many others followed
so in this the rest of the talk I will
concentrate of course on the fhe as I
already announced I would start with the
theoretical description and then I will
give a few details about the
implementation and in the rest of the
workshop you're going to see way more
details about all of those construction
or at least the majority of them Young's
who is gonna talk later about IANA
jessica is gonna talk about few Julia's
gonna talk about palisade and and so on
so I'm looking really looking forward to
all those talks and to all the details
but for now I will just concentrate on
on tfhe so before I continue yes if
there are any questions so yeah yeah
before you move on can you go back yes
sure just make a remark oh so you were
plus see find these skins based on how
the multiplication works
so these GS debut like thing so this is
a distinction between so G is very
multiplication and then you and TFA tree
is nobody argues in so multiplication is
done differently MTF a tree so the
mentation of bootstrapping now if we
think of this as a classification in
terms of how multiplication is performed
few are in a sense their own category
and there can be a different line to
explore where esw multiplication is used
to actually perform the computations
which is in fact the house is that it
was presented in that so yeah I just put
them all together because few and key
features GSW like ciphertext
yeah it's not a very like I put many
many things under the carpet it was like
a that's why I put them under I don't
know I know I know I'm it's also a I
just
to make this free market because that's
also presenting these two by in some
sense I think they're just repeating
what yeah it was a written or said some
time to clarify that
so you nthe them they're on
multiplication to establish yes yes yes
absolutely but yeah as I said many
things under the carpet but thanks for
the remark yes any other questions in
the meantime yes out if the cheaper for
multiplication and division supporting
or not so I'm gonna I'm gonna get a bit
more detail in I'm gonna start talking
about the FEC right now so just wait a
little bit for the morphic encryption
level ladies teams are only based on lwe
problems are there any other
construction based on group algebra and
other approaches so as I said before not
only on RWE problems as I said there is
like a crew based teams and the
approximate GCD I show at the beginning
that there is a stream based on
approximately City I'm not aware of all
the construction existing I know that
there are many line of research trying
to find solution that are based on
different problems but I'm I'm
personally not aware of anything that
has even our remarkable result but if
anybody has other comments on this of
course feel free do too
there are many attempts they're just not
very successful so far yeah okay great
and the last question out Wendell
encrypted loops while and control
statements like break and continuing
encryption domain well they're automatic
encryption scheme have to be oblivious
which means that every secret that
requires an if condition our while
condition and so on needs to be
performed in the worst case possible so
if you want to perform an if as example
you have to evaluate at the same time
the if condition and the else
mission and then make a choice between
the two of them automatically and
similar things can be done for a while
and if you want to break actually you
can not really break because breaking a
computation will mean like give some
some information about it and I don't
think this is possible so really you
evaluate the worst-case operations I
hope this answers the question
okay I am too black Rene I will continue
so I'm gonna hand her right now in the
tfhe in the description of the tfhe
scheme so as I said I'd start with the
basic construction and then I will talk
about the gate was trapping vertical
packing and look-up tables and then just
finish with some implementation results
so as I was saying before tfhe is starts
at the beginning as an improvement of
the scheme few proposed by the kinda
chancho which is a GSW based
construction but as Daniela remarked
there are of course difference compared
to GSW so what is very interesting in
the in the few paper is that the paper
is able to build a fully Omo morphic
encryption brick so it's like a really a
little brick that you can put together
many of those bricks to build any
possible circuit so the brick itself
perform the obstruct and NAND gate so
why are none first of all because with a
NAND gate you can really build that
every every binary gate that you would
like and the system amorphic operations
have a little problem in noise that
grows after every operation well the
bootstrap NAND gate takes care of this
node by doing a little bootstrap every
time the noise is for it the NAND is
performed so it's really a brick that is
ready to be used to build any possible
flume amorphic encryption construction
that you can imagine now the schema what
is very very interesting is that in you
commit chant your contribution the
evaluation of this bootstrap navigate
the particular a bootstrapping is
extremely fast so of course compared to
Anandi clear text gate the operation is
quite slow but compared to all the
previous result in bootstrapping this
was extremely exceptional because the
bootstrapping before I said it was very
costly and when I say very costly at the
beginning was not even thinkable about
performing a bootstrapping practice then
we were we went down to maybe years to
perform a bootstrapping then two weeks
today's and then two minutes but I think
nobody before and behind me ChaCha was
able to get under the second pair
bootstrapping and so it's significantly
improved with respect to what happened
before and the bootstrapping keys that
are used in the in the construction are
a bit large day ever they are one
gigabytes bootstrapping keys so in 2016
we were of course studying this paper
and together with Nicola Maria in the
Malika we observed that there was space
for improvement and so we started by
building a effigy which is initially an
improvement of the gate bootstrapping I
will call it gate boost droppings from
now on which is still slow compared to
the two before but improves the with a
factor the the preposition by few so
instead of performing a bootstrapping
and bootstrap NAND gate in less than a
second we perform in less than 0.1
seconds and also we reduced the size of
the bootstrapping Kizer from a gigabyte
size to a bunch of megabytes now when we
were improving the bootstrapping
the technique that we observed that
could be used to improve the
bootstrapping we noticed that they could
be used also to improve some level
constructions and so in the year later
we proposed an extension of the tfhe
schema to the level version where we
perform fast computation for small Deb
secrets of course you're not trying to
bootstrap we proposed new techniques to
evaluate the level of evaluation to
improve level evaluations and I'm gonna
show you later in the talk an evaluation
of a lookup table and also we proposed
the annual strapping which can be used
to help level circuits so you might
think why is this bootstrapping in the
level version and not in the bootstrap
version well because bootstrapping can
be also used as our support to level
operation it doesn't really give you if
you don't want a polymorphic encryption
scheme can be also using some sort of
way to help level computation but let's
ignore for now this this little detail
and during this improved
of the level version we saw that there
was still something that could be
improved in the bootstrapping itself and
so we reduced the time of the gate
bootstrapping down to 30 milliseconds as
well so this is a bit the overview of
the contribution I will now get into the
details of the scheme so first question
is why tfhe so fhe as you can imagine is
for volume amorphic encryption the t is
for totals so what we used is the real
torus I have a question is this a little
boostrap done implicitly for each and
every nand gate or does it have to be
called explicitly noise donna is done
it's done for every nand gate at least
the construction is a NAND gate with the
post wrapping you don't have to call it
explicitly it is implicit it's not
necessary you can of course perform
another gate in a different way but this
is a kind of different construction in
the gate bootstrapping yes is implicit
if the NAND operation are bootstrapped
how come is there a need for secret
level bootstrapping well because in the
gate bootstrapping version you are
performing an operation and the
bootstrapping operation in bootstrapping
what I what I said before is that we
might prefer sometimes to perform
leveled operations so not perform the
bootstrapping for a long time and then
perform the bootstrapping only when it's
needed so the gate bootstrapping version
when we bootstrapped every single binary
gate and the secret level bootstrapping
version are quite different are two
different approaches if you want I'm
gonna give more details later if in the
talk
I think I answered the Q&A okay so as I
said tfhe because of the Taurus so the
Taurus is just the real numbers modulo
one tourists the Taurus has a very nice
Zed module structure and when I say that
modules what I mean is that if we take
tourist element we can add them together
and there is the the addition is well
defined so the Taurus is an abelian
group we can also perform an external
product with integer coefficients so if
you take Taurus element in blue in my
slide and an integer element in red and
you perform the multiplication the
result is in the Taurus and the
multiplication is well defined but
unfortunately the Taurus doesn't have a
ring structure so it means that if you
try to multiply two elements in the
Taurus they are not the multiplication
is not is not well defined so it's not a
ring and as well as you have this Zed
modular property on the Taurus you can
easily extend it to Taurus polynomials
so in this talk I will use the shortcut
notation at TN of X as noted in the
slide
and when I say TN of X I mean
polynomials with coefficients in the
torso real modulo 1 reduce modulo xn
plus 1 and this the set as our module
structure where r is the set of integer
polynomials reduced modulo xn plus 1
during sorry so as well here we can
perform an addition between torus
polynomials so well defined external
products with integer polynomial well
defined but when we try to multiply
tutorials polynomials well the
computation is is not defined the
multiplication is not defined ok so this
was just a little bit an introduction
now what are the cipher texts that we
use in practice in the tfhe construction
we have three ciphertext types the first
one is the lwe a ciphertext now
not reintroducing a dlw problem I think
it was already well introduced by the
speaker before me and in the previous
days of course if anybody has a question
I will be glad to reintroduce some W but
I don't think it's there's me so LW is
ciphertex for us encrypt tourist
messages so messages in the tourist not
necessarily binary messages they can be
different message spaces and we use
binary tree is a binary secret keys the
ciphertext is of the form a B where a is
the random vector of torus elements MB
is just equal to the inner product
between the secret s and the mask a plus
what we call the phase which your
practice is just your message mu plus
some little gushin ever now in the
figure that I show in the slide I have
the unlocked representation of your
cipher text and the locked presentation
so when I say unlocked I mean that we
can see of course the damask which is
public and we can see the face when we
see the face we of course can easily see
what the message is so I cannot write in
the slide but in here you can imagine
that this is the torus so represented
like a donut on the bottom you have zero
in here you have one third in here you
have to first so in here I'm encrypting
the message one third and I encrypted by
applying the secret key so producing the
quantity B so I'll say when I decrypted
I will compute to be - a s I will find
out the face and once I have the face I
just need to round the face to the
nearest message possible and retrieve
the message so same exact thought can be
done for the second time of ciphertext
which are the Ringel w/e ciphertext it's
just a ring extension of lwe our
messages are not anymore
tohru's messages but our torus
polynomial messages with n coefficients
sorry
the secret keys are gonna still be
binary
secret keys but in this case we see them
as polynomials and the ciphertext is not
going to be a vector of n plus one
element but just composed by two
polynomials a and B where a is a random
polynomial M B is obtained as well as
the product between the secret and the
masker plus the error plus the message
and the error is still Gaussian and then
we go to the third ciphertext type which
is the ring just W cipher text which is
stead of encrypting Taurus messages of
Taurus polynomial encrypts integer
polynomials uses the same exact secret
here the ring and W is so a binary
polynomial and the ciphertext is a
little bit different so the cipher texts
are billed as an addition between a
matrix Z and the message multiplied with
this matrix G 2 now the matrix Z is just
a list of Ringel W encryption of 0 like
the ring and W encryption that we saw in
here encrypting 0 so it's just imagine
it as a matrix every line is a wrinkled
W encryption of 0 instead the matrix G 2
is called the gadget matrix and is a
block diagonal matrix and in the
diagonal you have this little gadget G
which is just a list of powers of 2 I
put powers of 2 just to simplify
generally we can put something different
with respect to 2 generally a power of 2
itself but for simplicity let's keep it
like this and the matrix G starting from
the matrix G we can define an operation
G minus 1 which is a decomposition of
variation with respect to G 2 so if we
apply this decomposition to a torus
polynomial we decompose the talapus
polynomial into little integer elements
and if we removed apply this
decomposition times G 2 we retrieve the
torus polynomial with the compost at the
beginning so it's like sort of inverse
operation okay so this was lots of
formulas so to give you just a visual
idea of the objects we are dealing with
I just show you this light so to
summarize LW
lwe ranges W are the ciphertext we're
dealing with we use lwe which are n plus
1 vectors encrypting 1 torus element
ring lwe encrypt polynomial elements so
n different tourist elements into two
polynomials and it reaches W you encrypt
an integer polynomial and the ciphertext
is a huge matrix and you can imagine in
here in every single line of this matrix
you have something that is a ring lwe
like ciphertext any questions until now
how about when Orion yeah sorry
how can you give a sense of how much
bigger yes I I put the numbers at the
end generally which was in practice in
tfhe we use this ciphertext are two
point something kilobytes of matrix yes
yes yes okay so in here generally you
have two times three four rows so six
ish we say depends on on your choices
but can be a distance six rows or eight
rows sometimes even four if you don't
need that much precision but yes I don't
know if this answered this question
raus one I would say between four and
eight but of course you can can vary it
depending on your parameter choices in
practice I think in in tfhe in the
library which was six rows I will double
check at the end but I think yes yes I
may be out of course yes okay thank you
okay so yeah I just introduced the
ciphertext but I didn't say what
operations can we perform on them so in
in LW and Ringle WS ciphertext the
linear combinations are allowed but
there is not a native product can be
defined on them of course there are
there are ways to perform the product if
you look at the bejeebies instance
papers you can just multiply elements of
the of the wrinkled W and then really in
your eyes but there is not what I what I
would call a native multiplication
defined and to go to a more native
multiplication I mean native take it
from very far we have to use GSW
ciphertext and the multiplication is
done by using dead accomplishing of with
respect to the gadget that I described
before so imagine that you have to ring
just W ciphertext 1 + + - what you do is
you decompose with respect to the gadget
one of them and you multiply with the
other by doing a normal matrix matrix
multiplication the result is going to be
a ring just about your ciphertext which
encrypts the product of the full message
of the two messages what was observed in
2016 by tfhe and also by brokers confirm
on the same ear is that there exists a
different product between that we called
the external product and that I would
call external product in the rest of the
talk which is a product between R ring g
SW so the big mattress and a ring LW e
ciphertext giving an output a wrinkled W
a ciphertext that encrypts the product
of the messages encrypted in in in both
ciphertext so in order to perform this
computation you just decompose with
respect to the gadget matrix this ring
lwe and then you perform a matrix matrix
multiplication between the decomposed
matrix and and your ring just double
your ciphertext and by observing more
closely we can see that actually the
internal product between two rings swo
ciphertext can be defined by a list of
independent ring external products so it
is sufficient to decompose this
independent lines of one of the two in
this case need
and then multiply them by seesaw
Performa independent drink external
products and you obtain the same result
so what we observed in KH is that in GS
in the in the bootstrapping in few the
operation that were performed during the
the bootstrapping routine were more
similar to this this kind of of products
were more internal product like
operations and the same amount of
information that was computed with an
external product internal products could
be computed by using an external product
so this is one of the major reason of
the of the improvement and starting from
this external product so the second the
second one this one we defined also a
gate a nooks gate which is in practice
anamorphic multiplexer or selector and
the milks gate so it's it performs
obstruction and addition and just an
internal product at any an input a ring
just w2 ring lwe so a big matrix and two
long vectors gives you an output a ring
and W II and this ring and W will
encrypt B 0 in case C is equal to 0 and
the 1 in case C is equal to 1 so the the
milk's gate is really largely using the
tfhe construction both in the bootstrap
construction and in the levelled ones
and now I'm going to try to enter more
into details in particular of the
bootstrap constructions I might stop if
there are any questions I wanted to make
a brief remark yes so the terminology
internal external product it's the
standard use of these words in
mathematics but I think that it can be a
bit confusing from being looking at this
from an implementation point of view
because what you call the external
product is an operation which is
performed internally by the internal
product so if you look at the code and
it would have been more naturally to
call the internal product code that
external in the
I will justify maybe the the terminology
at least this is why we call it this way
so as I said it's clear to me why you
call it no but maybe for the others yeah
yeah I just wanted to make this
clarification for people who are less
familiar with the algebra and the code
then I think the terminology seems that
it is used in perfectly clear to me and
the terminologies mathematically
accurate yeah ok ok ok now in case I
yeah
ok thanks for the remark ok any other
question until here
no look you an agent ok so let's move to
the gate bootstrapping
application so in it's already six
twenty five I don't have much time how
long do I have left
I mean you can take you can take some
extra time maybe 10 extra minutes if you
want ok I will try to fit everything in
10 minutes ok so in the case of gait
bootstrapping please avid even feel free
to stop me when when I'm passing the
time when I'm going too much so in the
case of there are two ways to do
bootstrapping of course you can choose
to be strapped up there every gate so
you have negating bootstrapping option
and as was asking before in one of the
question you have you can also have this
secret bootstrapping so where you put
strapped after a larger amount of level
operations so in the slide that follows
I will just concentrate on the gate was
trapping force if it was trapping I
don't have enough time so in case there
are any question I will take them
offline so the bootstrapping idea is to
initially reduce the noise in ciphertext
so I imagine that we can see in x-ray I
assign fur texture and this is what we
see inside this instance we are
encrypting the message 1 alpha and there
is lots of noise so the message could be
anywhere in this red part and what we
would like to give an output is a fresh
message so a message encrypting a
ciphertext encrypting a message with
less noise so the the where the message
is on the torus depends of course on on
the face on the message plus the error
which can be computed by computing B
minus SS and what we would like to do
with the gate bootstrapping
is depending on where the message or the
face if you want is in them in the torus
is one of the slices we would like to
give you in output something that that
is the output to message so in case that
existence we have that the message is in
here in this in this in this slot then
we would like to give you an output lwe
ciphertext with the message ve plus 1
with low noise so in order to do that we
are gonna try to play with the with this
wheel let's call it wheel and we're
gonna try to compute a morphic LED
position of the message in the wheel
rotate the will of a number of
some corresponding to the message and
extracted the ciphertext that correspond
to that supposition so to do that we fix
the initially what we call the
accumulator which is a vector containing
in each coefficient the possible output
and then we're gonna do a blind rotation
so rotate blindly because we don't know
the secret key this will of a number of
position corresponding to to feed the
face and then we will finally extract
the ciphertext corresponding to this V
position so this is the way they gave
restricting is performed to give a more
schematized idea this is the the
structure of the gate bootstrapping
again the green elements are lwe
ciphertext so you have LW input and
output the accumulator is going to be a
ring lwe and the rotation of the
accumulator is going to be computed by
using the nukes gate I described before
and in order to rotate the rotation is
going to be established according to the
bootstrapping key which is a ring just W
ciphertext encrypting the bits of the
secret key so this is the entire
structure the blind rotation is the most
costly part but with the external
product II it's it's quite fast this is
I'm gonna give the timings at the end so
this is actually anything I wanted to
say about the the gate bootstrapping I'm
gonna move very quickly to the level
construction and in here I'm gonna
present so another way of using the
milk's gate so in here in the gate
bootstrapping we use it to perform this
blind rotation to compute to rotate the
accumulator in the level construction
we're going to use to evaluate the
lookup table so as I said lwe encrypt
messages on the torus ring lwe encrypt
polynomials and if we concentrate on
ring lwe we can observe that actually a
ring and W a message a polynomial is
just a large container and in each
coefficient of the container we have
total Smith so just different torus
messages now when we want to evaluate a
lookup table at least in Phe we fix the
lookup table of something that looks
like in the slide
you have binary inputs and Taurus output
so in this case I have three inputs and
two possible out on so forth the
dimension depend on on which kind of
lookup table you want to evaluate and
those lookup tables are largely used in
crypto so to evaluate a lookup table
generally what you do is that you take
one of the column of the lookup table
and you you use your inputs in Eirik cx1
to select the output you're looking for
as instance if you are looking for the
output corresponding to 0 you will give
an input all zeros in here and every
single level of the new state are going
to take out from the from the list the
outputs corresponding to one so it's
going to always keep the output
corresponding to 0 until at the end the
you rest will remain with a single
output which is the one you were looking
for now in tfhe those nukes gates are in
even input
Ringel w/e ciphertext on the Sigma part
and ring just about your ciphertext on
them expert sorry so of course in
wrinkled w/e as I said you have a large
container so putting a single message
inside will be a bit of waste of space
so an easy way to improve this technique
is instead of putting a single message
in your ring LW is to put s elements all
these outputs correspond to every input
and evaluate this nukes tree in order to
obtain the output all the output
together in a single pass now the point
is that in here we have in India Qi at
least we have a bit as something around
1,000 slots let's call them slots a very
with abuse of terminology and it's not
that easy our list is not that common to
find a lookup table that has 1,024
outputs so in here even if you pack all
your output together most of the time
you're gonna waste space so in order to
prevent this wasting of space we're
gonna try to move the packing from
origin
tell it to vertically so this packing
can be used even if you have a single
output and actually it's way more easier
to fill the packing in vertical way
because to fill it you just need a 10
bit input which is quite more common
than our 1,024 output now of course you
cannot use the same technique as in here
and there is is not that trivial you
have to think about a different solution
to use the vertical packing and this is
what we did in tfhe now in this example
imagine that the lookup table outputs
were able to fill for Ringel w/e
ciphertext and the one I'm looking for
is exactly in here so to evaluate this
thing I'm gonna try to select at the
beginning the block I'm looking for so
the second one by using a very small
simek's tree way smaller than the moocs
tree I show you before and now that I
have a single Ringel w/e output I want
to extract this red guy in here and to
extract him I'm gonna perform a blind
rotation as in the same way as I did
indicate for strapping proposal by using
the different inputs this blind rotation
is going to bring this element in the
constant position and I will just
extract the constant position by doing
an extraction from wrinkle we2 al w e
now this is way more efficient compared
to the previous seem extreme u k--'s
evaluation because in here in the blind
rotation you don't have to ^ the milks
you evaluate as in the previous two
milks tree you just have d- tree element
milk so to evaluate so it's extremely
improved with respect to before now of
course you may say yeah but I can have a
solution or a good look up tables where
I have less inputs and more outputs well
there's not a problem the two techniques
the horizontal packing and the vertical
packing can be actually mixed together
and you can perform a square packing and
mixing the two solutions so I'm gonna
quick move on the implementation results
it's gonna take me two slides only sorry
for the delay so very quickly I just
wanted to say that all
the gfh system is implemented in c c++
and is available on github on the
chiefest library you have all the
bootstrapping
the gates bootstrapping implemented like
all the different binary gates
unfortunately the secret bootstrapping
and the level operations are not already
included in the TFG library the official
release but they're already implemented
at least the secret bootstrapping and
some level operation in an experimental
repository that is also available on
github so very quickly the timings the
gate was trapping as I said at the
beginning took in 2017 40 milliseconds
but we updated the library with new
secure parameters and also the the
computers evolved in three years
so right now depending on your machine
the bootstrapping could take between 10
and 20 milliseconds and all the binary
gates cost the same and in practice with
this timing you can evaluate about 17
structure binary gates per second the
simple bootstrapping is a little bit
more costly I didn't give details but it
can be used to refresh the outputs of a
level evaluation and all the level
evaluation which are mainly MOOCs is
cost thirty four microseconds so in
practice just to give you an idea if we
want to evaluate a lookup table as the
one I described before by with 16-bit
inputs and eight big outputs this will
take you only one second by refreshing
the outputs the size of ciphertext as I
was announcing already before we have LW
ease which are about 2.5 kilobytes
Ringel W is eight kilobytes and bring
just a belief 48 which is six times the
size of wrinkled W E and you can encrypt
the one message in and the bonhomie and
up to 21 24 messages in wrinkled WN
reading just about you and I think I'm
I'm finished so just to conclude some
subsequent work to tfhe not only TF h is
implemented for CPU as in in the ghz
library but there are also GPU
implementations qhc and new FH here two
examples TV is also using some neural
network
application an example is the paper by
books at all at crypto 2008 China and
the tfhe chimera solution presented at
AI - concerning a - amiran is going to
tell us more about it
in the inner stock the end of the day at
least for Europe end of the day we have
also multi key encryption solution as I
was saying before when I answer one of
the questions at least multi key
solution Basel jpg and also tfh is using
some NPC construction I think probably
how is going to give you a bit of
details about this onion ring around
construction using tfhe and I think I'm
finished I'm sorry for taking more time
than expected thanks a lot for your
attention and of course if you have any
additional questions I'm I'm here to
answer them yes seven minutes are you
able to perform batching when you do
ciphertext multiplication similar to the
batching techniques used in bgv like
schemes to multiply many integers in
parallel no not in the official list
that is not like I suppose you're
talking about the SIMD solutions not
exactly I mean the the batching in chief
Ichi is a bit different like the the
vertical packing and the lookup table
evaluation I showed you is the kind of
packing we're using we mainly use the
packing the polynomial packing so every
single coefficient of the polynomial is
a slot that's why I was saying abuse
because slots are more like the SIMD
slots in general but no there are not
batching techniques as in as in BGP
so you know perhaps one way to describe
it is that in terms of batching that you
described is different because in gdb
you're batching that you're packing the
inputs and then you can operate on all
of them in parallel
what you described is a way to pack the
outputs exactly yes I'm not it doesn't
apply it doesn't give a way to pack the
inputs yes exactly
any other question yes Larry having just
a high-level question talk a little bit
more about the applications of th you
wear this types of computations is
useful and what are the potential
limitations which types of computations
are are not easy to do with Jeff eg so I
I think there are many possible
application like the neural network
application as shown by by boss or at
all or by the the Shiva chika Vera
solution and also it not the chimera
paper actually there are new electric
application that can be can be shown and
the double strapping can be used to
solve those those applications as I said
like in this slide as you see like multi
key every time you have a multi key
solution that you would like to solve we
propose at least a multi key scheme for
it I think it's still now maybe the only
multi Keys team implemented but I might
be wrong at least when he when he get
out he was the only multi key stream
implemented in practice in the NPC
computation you can use a tfhe as a
support to those operations and yeah
those ones are the one I have in mind
right now everything that is like this
the max computation or a comparison is
extremely efficient with tfhe some
limitations may be we are we're of
course less efficient than maybe a BG v
BF reconstruction or even here when it
comes to packing multiple ciphertext and
performing computation in parallel but
as I said so it's it's the schemas
feature interesting feature and robux
and all this team actually as the
teachers and drawbacks and what is nice
is actually what would be nice is to
actually be able to take advantage of
all of them or all the features together
and this actually
could be done as shown by chimera by
building bridges between all of them and
so taking advantage of one or the other
depending on the application so yeah I
would say this thanks for your question
Yuri what's the main reason if it is
Spartan if you so I have to make a
little remark on this so few after th II
came out was already improved so I
suppose probably Jessica is gonna give
more details about it so there are a few
reason about the initial improvement at
least the external product it's one
reason in Kiev III we use the dedicated
FFT library let me see the MUX
construction the the MUX routine brought
some at least the way we express the
formula of the the blind rotation is a
bit more efficient compared to at least
our initial implementation some other
things
well maybe the fact that we work on 32
and 64-bit integers allows us to perform
native operations so we have again also
in that and probably there is another
reason I'm missing but yeah I think
those ones are the major ones and I also
have a question about from Eduardo could
you provide some estimation about the
computational cost of adding tfhe
ciphertext if I understood correctly you
can do addition as integers without
using any bootstrapping absolutely yes
it's like the the cost of an addition
between I don't know Turing lwe
ciphertext is just an addition between
all the elements themselves this is this
is of course can be performed I cannot
give you like I don't have timings but
it is extremely fast it's quite a
negligible compared to to the other
computation way faster of course then
the external product which took 34
microseconds but I don't have an exact
timing right now but you can say that
essentially encryption decryption in
addition are the same as lwe and all
others absolutely yes yes yes the real
difference is the multiplication and
boost
yes yeah you can just take figures from
the other schemes and maybe practically
the same code
yes exactly okay so thanks a lot ilaria
no two minutes until the next talks may
take five minutes to give you time to
set up okay thanks a lot thanks
everybody again for the attention